hi um can i get the bts meal please
[Music]
what's up you guys i'm joelle and i am
so excited to try
the bts meal at mcdonald's i'm super
excited that they're doing this
mcdonald's collaboration because
they're just so powerful i admire their
work ethic i love
their fashion so much and i'm actually
with my sisters
they're just so talented i am a recent
army
we have another housemate who he showed
us a bunch of bts
videos i actually stayed up till 2am
last night
watching bts videos ever since i have
been obsessed with these boys
not only do they make music but also
they're like so
fun as human beings i'm obsessed
unfortunately
i don't think there are gonna be photo
cards that's okay it's okay
because we've got the meal
[Music]
we got the good fries ten piece chicken
mcnugget
sweet chili and a cajun sauce so people
are really excited about these because
they're limited editions they have
the hangul writing of the sauce names
which is super cute
our medium coke all right we're gonna
try the cajun
first okay let's go it's so pretty this
is what the cajun sauce looks like
cheers cheers why does yours have a
growth
hmm i taste mustard you get the
sweetness
of the occasion and then like as you
keep eating it's like oh there's a kick
it's going it's going up
tastes like bad queso okay girl
it's got a slow burn it's really creamy
really sweet with like a light spicy
aftertaste
wait it's so good what would you rate it
out of five cajun sauce gets eight five
four three three point five four point
five i'd say four our second sauce we're
trying the sweet chili
baby oh that could have been in my mouth
okay so what i'm getting is that the
boys like spice
they do say you know i got that heat
what what kind of heat are they talking
about
oh it's good that's good it's what the
sweet and sour wishes it was
yes there is definitely a vinegar flavor
to it this tastes like it would be
in an asian restaurant oh she's sweet
and savory but she's also a little spicy
we could just get this from the chinese
grocery store and dip our mcdonald's in
it when they discontinue it yeah
honestly it reminds me of
sweet chili sauce that i would eat with
my lumpia
hell yeah hell yeah brother i'm gonna go
ahead and give it a four
nine only because i liked the other one
better i think i want to give this a
five i think i like the sweet chili
sauce i was gonna
i was just gonna give it a five two yeah
unanimous fives all around
did bts crush it with this meal yes it's
cute
this meal gets a 5 out of 5 from me and
i'm not just saying it because i love
bts but like it's just a great meal
definitely worth it especially for these
sauces mcdonald's keep
keep these sauces i wish it came with a
card though
i wish there was some sort of physical
memento from the meal but if you go on
the mcdonald's app which i'm on right
now for the bts
meal it says go backstage oh oh my gosh
that's so funny
it's like a 360 vr view
of bts and you can like literally move
around
to see them hanging out at this really
decked out mcdonald's i guess we get the
meal and check back
next week for an inside look with our
exclusive bts flip book
like week after week they're giving us
they're giving us i guess we're gonna
come back to mcdonald's
every single week now that i'm thinking
about it i can't give this meal a five
out of five
i have to give it a seven out of seven
one for each of the boys you know what
i'm saying
[Music]
you